I think Logan's another guy whether you
like him or not I think he's the he's
got the pedigree to one day run it
doesn't mean you're going to support his
policies correct but he is a guy that's
going in the direction of one day
running 20 30 years he could do it so
maybe he's sitting there saying what
would the rock do
he distanced himself from me well maybe
I got to stop defending this guy and I
gotta distance myself from him I wasn't
going on the angle of you know Hillary
Clinton call to all these guys no I was
going more What playbook is he follow I
understand exactly what you're saying
but I would I would disagree and the
reason I would disagree is because that
would
that that requires a degree of thought
and intellect that Logan Paul does not
presents
he's an idiot no I know he's an idiot
he's not thinking that far ahead he's
literally someone has told him say this
and he said it